would you say it's more companionship
yeah because I'm gonna ask you because
you actually date younger men
um yeah it's companionship and I won't
judge a young man my I've said it
already earlier on my ex was a lot
younger than me and age was totally
irrelevant there are some gaps there are
things that he won't know and I won't
know and then somewhere you sort of just
meet in the middle but you get
companionship you you know I I was in
love we were I could say we were
genuinely in love you know I'm not going
to talk about the reasons we broke up
but yeah we were together four years and
that was with someone younger than me I
had companionship I had friendship I had
someone that understood me I had love I
had someone that looked out for me it
was actually a great cook I'm a bit lazy
at that
um you know I used to go over to his
home and there was always food food
waiting for me not because I couldn't
you know go in the kitchen and make
something it was a real relationship so